доброго дня дорогі друзі мене звуть
сергей від каїну та консул аутизм європа та
мама дитини з аутизмом
якщо до вас у групу чи вам на курс
потрапила така дитина не бійтеся йому це
хороший хлопців ну просто є проблеми у
його проблеми іноді сенсорні іноді
проблема у нього неврологічний досі
часу вчені не можу сказати точно що з
ним але з вами не говорить і тому що не
хоче тому що він не може він іноді
виявляє агресію не тому, що він
сердиться на вас тому що він не може
інакше себе висловити лише так іноді
вони не можуть керувати своєю справою
але не дай боже уявіть
паралізованої людини яка все
розуміє дати зрозуміти що він все
розуміти не може і коли ми йому
розповідаємо про квадратики трикутники
а він усередині вже знає таблицю множення
і не може це проект тільки уяви
собі ті собі що відчуває ця дитина
вони вимагають особливої ​​уваги по-перше
такі діти важко йдуть на контакт
у них немає зорового контакту вони не
дивляться у вічі вони не завжди з першого
рази повторюють на прохання те, що ви
пропонуєте їм зробити або сказати
як правило, у них завжди зустрічається
порушення мови
та чи повна відсутність річі або
порушення фрази розмовної мови
порушення звуковимови людина
який працює з такою дитиною
повинен розуміти яка дитина перед нею
але не забувати, що в першу чергу це
дитина та всю тактику поведінки та роботи
будувати саме від того, щоб знайти
контакт з цим ремонт
незалежно яке б не демонстрували
бога попереду не краще звичайно перед
роботою поспілкуватися з батьками це
перше і дізнатися у них які переваги
і в нього є чомусь там може бути і
ефірі з що він більше любить і тоді
коли вже
дитину ви вже приблизно знаєте він
там машинки якась вузенька печиво і
ви вже розумієте чим його можна залучити
1 contact стимуляція це як і наочний
матеріал іграшки оточенні дитини
навколо тому дитину середа вона
потребує соціалізації дитині як
навик потрібно щеплювати спілкування зі
однолітками дивними з батьками
з чужими сторонніми людьми вчити його
потрібно вчити спілкуватися в соціумі
перебувати в соціумі та співіснувати в
цьому середовищі то навіть якщо якийсь
внутрішній страх є це лише
щось не пішло тому що ви думали
зробити це під руку і все але не
відступайте від того, що ви для себе
помітили звичайно треба дуже чітко для
себе розмежовувати строгість і
жорстокість та не можна ось тут ці поняття
так само як і любов до дитини до
розуміння та потурання це теж
абсолютно різні речі тут дуже чітко
потрібно ставити ось цей кордон у
розумінні що є щось, що може я
так люблю і ось так але не можу їм
відмовити це не кохання це потурання
і це загалом
робляться дії для спрощення собі
зараз ось якогось конкретного
там результату а дуже важливо
індивідуальне заняття того, що ми на
індивідуальне заняття навчаємо дитину
як правильно виконувати той чи монолог
потім ми це все закріплюємо до групи
володіє іс-4 не бути індивідуальними
п'ятниця останній день це груповий це
дуже важливим пунктом групове заняття
тому що такі діти їх особливо не
можуть демонструвати чудово
виконання завдання на індивідуальному
але коли група інші діти це
них це більше навантаження пристрасть і не
можуть вже не показуйте навички тому
ми їх навчаємо не лише індивідуальну
коли двоє людей перебувають ще в грудях
це все закріплюємо і повторюємо ми
сядемо засліночка і за тим, щоб дитина
справді не
це максимально йому зоровий контакт
ви привертаємо до себе і природно йде
мотивація ми зобов'язані вірити такій
мотиваційний святих для того, щоб
дійсно дитина активувати щоб
він вчиться щоб він пакет цьому навчати
якщо мотиватор вони в такому разі
дитини неможливо жодним чином
насіння з моєю само собою зрозуміло
будемо говорити так поведінкою на
полягає це не криві 3 частина сім'ї
красиво сидить рівно це природно
поряд з дитиною бажано її стежити
на перші місця для того, щоб
справді
його якимось чином лелечка проколю за
ми на перше місце таки виставляємо
поведінкова побутові моменти
якщо дитина не розуміє, що потрібно
сидіти за столом і не важливо для якого
процесу то ти не можеш ні який
процес за цим столом здійснити будь
то їда або це заняття це вже не
має а для дитини це вже не важливо
коли дитина сіла за стіл 3 секунди
взяла ложку в рот і втік прожовуючи
ходу потім знову повернувся це не процес
ніколи такою поведінкою не зможемо
рухатися як би далі пояснювати
дитині для чого потрібна тому під
контроль беруться всі ті моменти на
які за великим рахунком багато
педагоги не те що не звертають уваги
вони навіть для себе не наголошують що
це і є ось ці найважливіші моменти
для фундаменту в подальшій роботі якщо
буде встановлено емоційний контакт
то дитина не даватиме істерик а
якщо буде естер яке це про що то
каже що дитина чимось незадоволена
нам знайти причину що трапилося що
дитини турбує коли усувається
причина то й немає приводу дитині давати
ось такий сигнал про обурення
але уявіть собі, що хтось натиснув
одну клавішу на піаніно, і ви чуєте
звук почуєте одна клавіша один звук
тому дитину в голові від одного звуку
може грати всі племена вони часто дуже
часто сенсорні перевантажені з цього
боляче дивитися на вас пряно вони
відчувають дуже сильне внутрішнє
напругу від цього життя вони не бачать
світ тому що бачимо його ми
ніс